I have something to tell you I don't
mind to tell you this for a long time
but I was scared very scared about how
you'd react so God why is it so hard to
save us oh yeah I'm gay
super gay I guess I've always been more
into girls than usual but it's just
still really weird for me to say that
I'm you know gay gay gay
I am so gay no I don't have a girlfriend
can't even imagine having one makes me
nervous to even think about kissing a
girl
I thought Tonya had Lyndsey a lady's ex
girlfriend Shirley current girlfriend
drama mom and dad can never know okay my
mom tried to set me up with her
neighbor's daughter my dad's still not
talking to me but whatever this is Who I
am
I'll get over it eventually I'll never
be one of those girls who turns into a
stereotypical lesbian did I get IPA on
my favorite flannel hold my beanie I
can't believe I'm gay I can't even
imagine being straight you know what I
I feel relieved like a weights been left
it I mean it took some time but now my
life is pretty great I'm happy I came
out
[Music]
I just feel like I'm gay you're welcome